what the United States says it will stop
mediation talks on the conflict in Sudan
because goals are not being met an
American delegation has been holding
talks and Jetta with the team from Saudi
that have helped broker several
ceasefires between Sudan's Army and the
rapid support forces but fighting has
continued despite the true steals
labor Morgan is in on demand near the
capital Khartoum and this with the
United States saying it's going to stop
mediation talks this is a major
development isn't it
it is indeed now uh both the United
States and Saudi Arabia made it clear
that before the previous ceasefire which
lasted for 72 hours and ended on
Wednesday morning came into effect that
should it be violated then talks would
be adjourned uh by the facilitators
between the Sudanese Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces now
during the period of 72 hours of that
ceasefire there was no fire fighter jets
flying there were no sounds of heavy
artillery an exchange of gunfire between
the paramilitary rapid support forces
and the Sudanese Army was not reported
in any part of the capital so it looks
like when it comes to that aspect of the
ceasefire that was respected but the
ceasefire also included no military
movement from either side and residents
in various parts of the capital reported
that they were kicked out of their homes
forced at gunpoint to leave their
belongings and their property by the
paramilitary rapid support forces so the
United States said that the ceasefire
was not fully effective in the sense
that not all all of its terms were
fulfilled and it's not clear If this
means that talks would be completely
adjourned and would no longer be held by
the mediators Saudi Arabia and the
United States and that talks are
completely over and that the delegation
or the representatives of the two sides
would return to Sudan or if talks would
be a postponed for maybe after the
Muslim holiday of Eid before tax resume
again that part has not been clarified
by the United States but people here in
the capital who we spoke about the
ceasefire and about the fact that that
talks would be adjourned they say that
they don't want another ceasefire they
either want to see the two sides reach a
permanent agreement that would end the
fighting completely or they want to
ensure that they are not forced from
their homes by the paramilitary rapid
support forces even if that means a
continuation of this war
okay thank you so much for that update
that is Heather Morgan for us and On
Demand